my name is unusual Kirsten you don't see
it very often especially my age in
younger and one day I was wandering
around SeaWorld and I went through the
food line and the girl working the cash
register was named Kirsten so I asked
her how she got her name and she said
that the house she grew up on was called
Kirsten place and her parents just like
the name so they named her after the
street but what's really funny about the
story is my dad is the one who named
that street he named two streets in
Spring Valley Caren Lane after my sister
in Kirsten place after me because he was
a developer and he got to make the
streets in that town
[Music]
I was actually abroad in New Zealand and
I was talking to a stranger about how I
wanted to go to a hiking trail further
off and she gave me your car for the day
just because I wanted to go to a hiking
trail that was far away she didn't even
know if I could drive let alone who I
was and gave me your card so I
definitely remember her she was
incredibly kind so once many years ago
when I was a student in Milwaukee
Wisconsin I was crossing a street near
my apartment in a not-so-great area and
a man approached me and took my scarf
and squeezed it across my neck an effort
to attack me and I was frightened and I
fought him off and ran home I've never
forgotten him what were the feelings you
were left with
of state of vulnerability that I had not
experienced before the one screams
remember
and a grocery store than the one in
front of me
notice that we didn't have money to pay
for food which would be for all our food
it was over a hundred dollars and I
didn't know her name or anything she's
just paper you know walked away I've
never seen her again but in my head I
thank God for her because she did help
out a lot when we needed her I remember
back in my hometown in East Texas this
stranger randomly ran up to me without
saying word to this day I still don't
know his name ran up to me handed me $20
and took off in the opposite direction
nobody he came running up to it so I
kept it it was 4th of July 1999 the
Starbucks in Coronado as sitting
enjoying some tea obviously kind of
looking around to see if there are any
beautiful women in walks a beautiful
women with their parents no less and I
found a way to start a conversation with
her and well nearly 20 years later we're
still together
[Music]
I met a stranger in the airport who's a
retired nurse that had saved about 80
children from a plane crash and that
left an indelible episode she was a
young nurse a lieutenant in the Air
Force and she was evacuating amber Asian
children from Vietnam at the the fall of
the Capitol and the plane crashed on
takeoff and she saved the children no
matter how badly injured she was she put
up with the pain to rescue those who
were dependent upon her and that made a
lot of difference for me so I was on a
cruise and I was just sitting like
looking at the view I had like lost my
family I didn't know where they were so
I was just trying to like watch the
ocean and watch everything and I was
kind of at like a very confused point in
my life like not really
what I wanted to do with it and this
random lady just came up to me with her
bottle of wine and like a book in her
hand and she just starts like talking to
me about her life and she was telling
you about how she was a nurse and she
was like doing public health and
teaching moms how to breastfeed and take
care of their babies and I didn't know
her name she didn't tell me anything
about her she was just very happy and
relaxed and she just walked away and
told me to have a nice day and that was
one time when I knew that I wanted to do
nursing so that was pretty cool no
kidding me
yep that's what I'm doing right now yeah
yeah yeah it's really cool I was ice
skating and there was a little
five-year-old girl she walked up to me
and she goes can I just tell you
something you are the most beautiful
girl I see today and literally made my
entire month because I don't know it was
just like I never got a compliment like
that from someone so little and I didn't
think it wouldn't matter cuz I don't
know it just did
so many years ago I was coming back for
a camping trip with my family and this
was pre late at night so sleeping in the
backseat of my brother was there as well
and for some reason which I don't
understand her this day the door opened
at the back and I actually kind of flew
out while we were on the middle of the
road going at probably 40 to 50 miles an
hour and so I landed on the road but at
this time I'm kind of still sleeping I'm
just like getting like what just
happened and my parents has drove ahead
because they didn't know this until
maybe five minutes later when my mom
heard the door kind of making a whoosh
sound at the back and all and looked
back which is oh my god they went to the
side and stopped immediately and at this
point that I cannot even sure where I am
what happened but luckily enough someone
who was driving up stalled because they
saw something the middle of the road
that resembled a person and they got out
of the car helped me to decide
completely lost and crying at this point
and they walk me back while my parents
walk back so we pick on a met in the
middle and yeah I don't remember his
face but for obvious reasons that's
someone who's basically changed my life
because I wouldn't be her first if they
ran over me when my parents like said
thank you to them in a newspaper and
stuff like that so some pretty cool and
crazy stuff so I had someone messaged me
on Instagram a long time ago and we kind
of befriended each other and then maybe
a year later they randomly messaged me
and asked if I wanted to go to the
Bahamas and I was like well that's kind
of weird but it was for a competition
that the he won for tinder to where we
would go on our like first date to swim
with sharks for the Discovery Channel
so I met a complete stranger in Florida
and we flew with a bunch of people and
went to the Bahamas to swim with sharks
and that was the first time I met him I
went to hike with my parents it was
really hot outside and we forgot our
water bottles and he was pretty pretty
pretty old and was sitting on a bench
and I was pretty dehydrated and he was
like getting some water out of the dwell
and putting it in his hands and he gave
it to me in his hands to drink and I was
so relieved that I can get some water
and I didn't even speak his language she
was Greek or something and yeah he gave
us all water like that was really nice
and I remember it to this
[Music]
so you all drink water out of his hands
yeah actually a gentleman I met about
six months ago and he's just complete I
guess you could say homeless or just not
doing too well we just had a great
conversation for about a half an hour to
an hour and it's honestly the most
frequent memory that I think about every
now and again do you remember what you
guys talked about family mostly he told
me about his kids
and how we missed him and how he was she
getting more for him and I was telling
him about how I wish I had a family like
that one day being able to raise my kids
in a healthy home really he just even
given it where he was he seemed as
inspiring as many of the people that I
know today who were doing much better in
life than even I am to be honest and he
saw life in a way that people don't
truly understand it anymore which is
everyone is equal that things like that
just sort of happened sort of like this
right now the stranger I remember I was
about four or five years old and a guy
broke into my house he came through my
window and he tried to abduct me and
then the neighborhood men all jumped on
and tackle him and the cops came and
arrested him so that's a stranger that I
remember and as the story goes I was
asleep during most of the incident I was
in Madrid Airport I've been visiting my
brother who was living there and we me
and my friend were in the queue and
there was his lady in front of us
maybe I'm 60 something and she just turn
around
and she started talking to us about the
power of the universe and the secret
which was actually the first time I ever
heard of that book but she was so it
wish it was really bizarre cuz she kind
of just appeared dropped all this wisdom
me my friends or thought they didn't say
anything and then she left and she never
saw her again and it was really bizarre
because we were both kind of questioning
whether it was even real she was both
had a very profound effect on both of us
we were camping and hiking and whatever
we had seen this lady hiking the trail
by herself who was maybe in her 50s and
I thought it was cool I thought I was
single on my 50s I'd still go out and do
this cool stuff you know and it was
weird because when we were camping then
she actually had the camp spot next to
us and came over and asked to share a
fire so she didn't have to make her own
or whatever I thought it was cool
because I don't know I have a big family
and I've never done anything like by
myself before hence I was like that is
I'm gonna do that I can do that I could
go hiking I could go invite myself to
strangers campfire or something like
that you know so I went to church once
and this lady I was like ten years old
sat right next to me never knew her
never met her obviously she's a stranger
and she gave me a dollar to give into
the basket and she just told me that she
will pray for me it from her rest of her
life and I just took to me because I
didn't know her and I told her I'll pray
for you as well and I was even like
really I didn't believe in religion in
the moment I still don't but I'm like
God if you're real
like take care of this woman I met her
at a camp and we were doing this
exercise of vulnerability and being able
to make eye contact with somebody you
don't know we were in this group of 50
people her and I were moving in the
circle moving from person to person and
when her and I my eyes we both you
started crying at that time I didn't
have a good relationship with my mother
and so when I saw her I felt like I saw
an older version of my mom but in that
time I really desire to have a better
connection better relationship with my
own mother that's just something that
was going on in my like my deep self the
stranger was here at the park and it was
an older gentleman that we stopped right
over here actually take a picture of us
believe it or not and did a fantastic
job he just stopped and like asked all
the right questions and like you know he
was a little eccentric to say the least
but he did a great job of taking the
pictures and it's just when I was
walking by right now I just happen to
remember him he haven't asked that
question so it's interesting I was
actually looking for a rock shop at
close to our area and I found this guy
that has
Rock shop in his basement he took me on
a hunting trip for Flint in that two
hour actually for our trip we found well
we were I think probably brothers of
another mother we became instant best
friends so it kind of seems like I've
never met a stranger that I didn't like
and some of them become best friends
[Music]